IceCube goes after you a lot oh yeah
those yeah gives you a hard time you
know what because I give him such a hard
time when we're working you know I'm so
I'm so silly and I'm constantly jabbing
at him like huge thing he's older so the
longer the day is to tire to get so I
catch him you know I quit we're doing
promo a present you'll see him like you
know you always has his glasses because
he tries to hide if he's falling asleep
huh
but as you know this definitely mean
there's nothing about this that means
that you're up yeah yeah it's bad so
like I call him on all this stuff like
in front of people might kill sleep and
his no no I shoot it what we're doing
were yeah yeah yeah he just goes he's
just so much stuff so when I'm not
around I'm not around he throws the jab
well cuz he does it on Instagram they're
everywhere fight back so look at these
Instagram look at this one right here
there's a picture of you yeah ice tube
should pick out a / yeah Kevin Hart
should pick out a purse to go with them
pants he's got somebody in production on
this side because these pictures aren't
even released yeah I don't even know we
must look at another one here and he's
saying right there begs to try on a
bikini oh he can cook his crack yeah
I don't know why you're laughing these
are just wrong okay it's wrong what he's
doing that's wrong they're wrong but I
will say that's our relationship man we
have a very fun relationship right you
know we like to give each other mess and
when we do we give it back and I think
that's the great thing about our dynamic
and that's movie you know the chemistry
that we have the friendship that we have
is real and I think it shows on camera
you definitely I've spent a lot of time
with the both of you off-camera and you
are real friends yeah and you get along
and you're funny together I mean on
these remotes we just roll you guys are
naturally that way that always comes
through in these films no it really it
really does man I think that's what I
love the most about working with Cuba
you know he started off as the guy that
you assumed was angry because he never
moved his lip his top lip is always
strength
that's all day all day that's his lip
all day kill you want to eat maybe I
guess and then after we got warmed up
you realize that's just that's just his
demeanor that's just my face but it's
not who he is man he's a good guy and I
couldn't ask for a better co-star in
this particular case so I'm lucky to
have him I'm glad to have a guy to go
back and forth with me cuz I'm silly
call him say well I'm sitting messing
with you about you walk I'd do things
like that to him all day right all day
meant not he don't walk like you but
it's not I'm saying if he did if he did
I would I would give it to him the same
right right he just doesn't and I do
know cute killed as well you know cute
does that annoys me no he makes noises
every time he sits down or gets up it
makes me so mad I don't know you not
people do stuff that gets under your
skin a little bit and like he's a rocker
when it's time to get up
Oh hilarious the ready set go get up hey
thanks for watching please subscribe to
my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please